oh and Amy your dress makes you look
like a mermaid
okay I'll see you in a little bit I do
not like Amy you're putting a lot of
effort into a joke I want you to sit
down and have a real conversation with
her the car's a piece of crap why do you
love it so much
you really want to know
I was two days out of the academy super
nervous saw this guy run out of a bodega
clutching a bunch of cash so I pursued
him on foot 11 blocks
finally catch him cuff him throw him up
against that car
turned out there was a for sale sign in
the window and it being the best day of
my life I bought it
thus began the debt
crushing debt
you do know me
no
only if you throw it ready
nice
ready uh-huh
[Applause]
what are you doing
you're trying to catch it in your nose I
got it I got it I got it all right let's
hope keep practicing okay
Peralta oh good news Peralta I found
someone from the night shift to relieve
you on your Stakeout still make Time
Square
um
you know Captain hold off on the relief
team we're already here plus I'm curious
to see what happens okay so cool
what did halt want just checking in how
you doing any progress yep watch
the key is volume I see that what's
going on thick Kovac what do you think
Amy sees in Teddy so you do like her I'm
just curious I mean I guess he's okay
looking and he's a good cop they're both
kind of dorky about police stuff also he
set the course record but that's nothing
I broke it like 20 minutes later
you want to know why she went out with
him and not you yeah
because he actually asked her out
[Music]
hey Amy check it out no way you won
coolest kill not even close it turns out
anyone can just buy themselves a
children's karate trophy smart yeah yeah
hey before you go
I wanted to ask you something of course
I was just wondering
are you wearing lipstick yeah I'm going
out with Teddy again does it look weird
I called my 13 year old niece for makeup
tips but I don't know if I trust her she
is so sexual
you look great
thank you
so what's up
oh it's not important I just had a
question about a work thing but have a
great date and we'll talk tomorrow yeah
okay
bye bye
Amy
hey thought I missed you Hey Jake
amazing assignment I have to admit
I'm a little jealous really well if you
want I could help you get fired I'm
really good at it
yeah
this is real this is happening look um
I don't want to be a jerk I know
you're dating Teddy and it's going
really well it's just what's going on
I don't know what's going to happen on
this assignment and if something bad
goes down I think I'd be pissed at
myself if I didn't say this
I kind of wish something
could happen between us
romantic styles
and I know it can't because you're with
Teddy and I'm going undercover and
that's just how it is but
anyway we're
not supposed to have any contact so I
should go America needs me
bye
actually I think you should stay
so we can all talk about the real reason
there's a problem in my relationship
with Amy which is you Jake but what now
huh about how you told her that you
liked her before you went Undercover
you like baby
um I did but that was many moons ago was
it because I know for a fact you also
told her when you got back and every
time you would she would get confused
and then our relationship would get out
of sync and if you ask me I think it's
because Amy liked you back
did you
Maybe
yes just say you still like her all
right fine I still like her
I'm thinking about asking around for the
last couple of weeks but it's hard so
much build up now you know not really I
don't ask people that I just tell them
when we're going great well it doesn't
matter now anyway because I told Dave to
go for it that was crazy stupid
sorry that was normal stupid I should
have told him to back off I can't go
around telling guys not to ask Amy out
because I like her and I'm too dumb to
do anything about it I can't make a
woman's choice for her I stand with
Wendy did I do that right after
everything that happened with Teddy and
all the cops I know who go out and break
up and then still have to work together
it's just too messy I got a new rule I
don't date cops
cool cool yeah actually that's funny I
have the same rule no more cops from
this point on it's strictly dating
criminals if you break up with them you
can always send them to jail forever
exactly nice and clean
hey did I do something to you are you
mad is this because I brushed all the
crumbs off your desk what no I don't
care about that
you never there in the trash
all right if it's not that then why are
you trying to keep me off this case oh
that
all right look the reason that I didn't
want to work with you is should I do
this in an accent so that I can undercut
some of the awkwardness I'm feeling no
good call remember when you told me that
you didn't want to date cops
that really bummed me out man Jamaican
yeah it was a bad choice I'm much better
at German so how did you know she was
the one
I'd love to answer that
um you know
just whenever I look at her face and the
attached physique and you
uh
[Music]
he makes me laugh
and you know there's really no one
else's opinion who I care about more
than her so
okay there's the buyer or maybe he's
just actually saying hi to the chef why
isn't he making the handoff oh crap he
saw us
excuse me
oh hey we were just looking for a place
to uh blink
yep
boink that's my preferred term for it as
well I love how beautiful you are I love
your face and I love your butt I should
have written this down first no no it's
okay go on I love how much you pretend
to like die hard I like the second one
you don't have to okay yeah
you're kind and you're funny and you're
the best person I know and
the best detective
also for reals I love your butt I love
yours too gross
Amy Santiago
will you marry me I planted the idea in
Jake's head eight years ago
oh hi I'm starting today detective
Santiago oh detective Peralta welcome
aboard
I'm hearing Wedding Bells
hi detective Boyle that actually really
slowed things down it took like four
years for me to forget that memory yeah
My Own Worst Enemy look no one gave me
the idea I decided to ask Amy to marry
me all on my own on April 28th there's a
typo in this crossword puzzle
foreign
I don't know what to tell you that's
just what I knew romantic epiphanies are
dope thank you Rosa they are dope
Santiago
before you go in there there's something
I have to say I'm sorry I said you were
a bad partner I was the bad partner
the truth is our job isn't always great
I mean sometimes it sucks but
it sucks a little less when I get to do
with you so when you said you were gonna
leave I freaked out and I was dumb I
should have been more supportive
you're a great detective and they'd be
lucky to have you
in fact
if it helps I wrote you a letter of
recommendation
which is riddled with spelling errors I
might add including the word
recommendation which is just I don't
have to tell you about that there's no
way there's four M's in that word right
I already turned down the job
seriously in the end you were right I
don't want to sit at a desk
and right now I like where I am
ah but thanks for thinking I'm great no
I take back all the things I just said
uh-uh you said I was a good detective
and you were nice this is my nightmare